normalerweise im laden kompletten
schwachsinn hoch und lustige videos
allerdings ist gerade etwas passiert wo
ich mir einfach gedacht hey ich spüre
gerade so eine unfassbare wut in mir und
ich möchte gerade einfach ein video
machen und reden es ist gerade der 26
märz 2009 10 13 uhr und das
europaparlament hat soeben für artikel
13 abgestimmt was kaputt
unsere wochenlangen proteste mit über
200.000 teilnehmenden leuten und fünf
millionen unterschriften edition wurden
schlichtweg ignoriert demokratie wollte
war auf jeden fall die abstimmung über
die urheberrechtsreform im
europaparlament und ich hab den live
stream um 12 55 oder so eingeschaltet
und habe dieses ergebnis gesehen und
dachte mir geil alter da sind fünf leute
mehr dagegen als dass leute dafür sind
mich erst gefreut und dann habe ich
allerdings herausgefunden
das ist die abstimmung war über
änderungsanträge das alles immer noch
nicht so ganz realisieren das heißt
wurde direkt zu beginn gesagt
ihr dürft nicht bei änderungen
vorschlagen artikel 13 und haben auf
jeden fall die richtige abstimmung über
artikel 13 beziehungsweise über die
urheberrechtsreform und da kam dieses
ergebnis bei rum 348 leute dafür und 274
dagegen artikel 13 ist somit offiziell
durch erst überlegt ob ich dieses video
hier auf meinem zwei analog hochladen wo
ich ja eher so kurze sachen hochladen ab
und zu ein paar dumme sachen und dieses
video hier hätte da hat perfekt gepasst
weil es noch ein kleines update ist
dies habe ich auf meinen hauptkanal ja
auch schon 24 ausgemacht so artikel 13
ich habe ja auch social media technisch
echte ordentlich gas gegeben was das
ganze thema angeht und ich fühle mich
einfach gerade so als müsste ich einfach
reden und das am liebsten mit zu vielen
leuten wie möglich denn das wichtigste
was wir jetzt wirklich machen müssen ist
am 26
mai wählen zu gehen bei den europawahlen
und einfach zu sagen politik so kann es
nicht weiter gehen also falls über 18
seid dann geht bitte wählen ende mai und
falls nicht über 18 seid dann bitte
redet mit euren eltern ihren verwandten
freunden und die zentral informiert
darüber was hier gerade so abgeht in den
ganzen letzten wochen ging es natürlich
immer um die urheberrechts reformen
artikel 13 allerdings immer mehr auch um
die politiker und deren aussagen und
deren verhalten die cdu csu oder einfach
die user blockiert menschen beleidigt an
ihre interessen mit lobby videos
beworben vier jungs ihr somit einen
scheißdreck auf meinungsfreiheit und
bericht sogar den koalitionsvertrag von
union und spd wollten sie die abstimmung
die jetzt gerade stattgefunden hat vor
in dem es die am samstag waren
stattfinden lassen einfach um das ganze
vorzuziehen zusagen reden demonstriert
egal wir haben ja schon abgestimmt als
die cdu und csu vor einigen wochen
unfassbar viele mails von uns bekommen
hat haben sie gesagt hey das sind alles
computergenerierte mir jetzt es sind
bots das sind doch keine echten menschen
und dann sind wir die boards auf die
straße gegangen waren über 200.000 leute
am samstag und dann sagen wir alle grund
bekommt jeder von unserer angeblich 450
euro bekommen haben was das ist echt und
fassbar und einfach alleine
sagte dass die petition mit über fünf
millionen unterschriften schlichtweg
ignoriert wurde
mir fällt wirklich nichts mehr als das
abstimmungsergebnis gerade gesehen hab
ich hab wirklich einfach mein handy
genommen und hat es einfach gegen die
wand geschmissen
es geht jetzt natürlich nicht um alle
politiker beispielsweise julia weder die
hat unfassbar gekämpft und nicht meine
allgemein waren ja auch 274 leute
dagegen und auch von den 378 oder für
man kann es ja sein dass da auch einige
dabei waren vielleicht ein bisschen
älter sind und eigentlich sich eher um
andere dinge kümmern echt ich will das
gar nicht jeden hier irgendwie
verurteilen aber ich halte weder caspari
sich der sich damit nun hat es auch die
straße gehen die verkehrssituation
gebrauch machen es wäre das immer
verteidiger überzeugt artikel mit der
über die mussten ihm das mikro
abschalten ihr wollte ich aufhören zu
reden das ist einfach eine
respektlosigkeit die kannst du doch so
nicht am tag legen
also ich kann es wirklich nicht in worte
fassen wie ich mich gerade fühle sogar
trotz noten hat gerade ein spiel
rausgehauen hat
wie gesagt erst vorgehabt dieses video
hier auf meinem zweiten album zu laden
allerdings ich finde sowas muss so viele
leute wie möglich erreichen und so viele
leute wie möglich sollten einfach wissen
vom 23 bis 26
in europa waren und dort hingeht wählen
wenn ihr über 18 seid und wir nicht über
18 seid dann sagen allen anderen
bescheid ich hab's auch dieses jahr
umgeschmissen bei dieser demo ich habe
so rom geschrieben und ich fühle mich
einfach nur beleidigt ich will nicht
sagen dass alles umsonst war
politik ist kein sprint sondern wir
ein marathon aber es ist einfach
trotzdem so unfassbar traurig dass man
sieht dass man einfach ignoriert wird
werden ja nicht mehr ignoriert sich
einfach gesagt wir sind gekauft
es ist echt nicht wahr ich hatte heute
eigentlich vorgehabt hier ein video zu
laden wie ich ein digitales mikroskop
fest wie bereits gesagt ich fühle mich
einfach gerade so als müsste ich dieses
video hier hochladen bevor ich demnächst
nicht mehr kann
allerdings wolle sich jetzt erstmal
dieses video aufnehmen weil wie gesagt
gerade war die abstimmung und ich habe
mich einfach da noch gefühlt bitte geh
wählen am 26 mai macht euch weiter stark
vertreten teure interessen und jetzt ja
das war es tatsächlich dann erst der
anfang
[Musik]